tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono farisei e siamo tornati su melo
nate per il primo episodio ho giocato
alla primissima demoni e lo neighbor non
sapendo che in realtà era uscita la
versione della madonna il confronto bene
oggi giocheremo a quella versione della
madonna che tanto ci può giocare anche
col joystick
vabbè ai ragazzi di non c'è il joystick
che sono youtuber del cazzo quindi
andiamo con la tastiera proviamo così
addirittura le animazioni ma siete scemi
quanto al giorno ero a previti è
diventato crisis cos'è sta roba
no vabbè fermi non è possibile io ho
giocato a sta roba da pochissimi giorni
fa mica è un trauma non ci credo mai
presente o premi quanto è cambiato
quanto bello mica nell'altro a malapena
ti dicevano che cosa devi fare
anzi conto diceva neanche qua minchia
parti che sei in macchina già sei scemo
entra dentro la casa e porta gli oggetti
all'interno bene ce l'ho appena
trasferiti alla nostra nuova house e c'è
subitissimo un palo della corrente che
deve scassare le palle
grazie ma quando ha adesso ce l'ho io la
casa grossa brutto pezzente media fa i
soldi con youtube a chiave e sotto la
pietra dietro la cassetta delle lettere
complimenti manifesto attaccato alla
porta nessun ladro se ne sarebbe mai
accorto complimenti per la sicurezza
premier ma mica pensavo fosse la pietra
cazzo detto la pietra fa il verso dei
corvi premi il tasto destro per lancia e
va per ariccia povero accordo credo di
avere appena visto il lancio più bello
della mia vita e ho appena avuto un
orgasmo si è incastrata in mezzo vabbè
va bene va bene si può fare perfetto sai
dovete lei infilo st chiave brutto corvo
di sean perdere la press sinistro quanti
problemi per entrare in casa poiché lei
sbarrate
qual è il problema cos'è
si faceva perché sbarrato una caccia il
piede di porco ma perché perché è
sbarrato una casa si era chiuso a chiave
spiegami quarto 6 paranoico cosa lo fa
tenendo premuto che bene perfetto un
corpo una chiave un piede di porco
grazie di dio benedetto
ecco questa è casa mia la riconoscono
all'ordine fantastici ma in tutto questo
ragazzi il vicino dove e quindi brutto
stronzo è casa mia questa ma cosa vuoi
ma si scende a questo paranoico ma il
sole enigmista sto tizio ha avuto del
latte non è un omicida ragazzi dobbiamo
intervenire subito era sì ho capito mi
ha sequestrato fatemi capire tutto
figlio di tutta è casa mia a questo si
guarda la mia televisione la mia
sfrattato il tuo pezzo di merda
terminate qualcuno rischia finite che il
corpo tono infilo tutto su per il culo
quindi ha quindi la storia che in realtà
io non sono
[Musica]
c'è la porta chiusa col codice ragazzi è
ancora qua la porta col codice
ancora non ho capito che cosa nasconde
dietro quella porta ma va bene tutto ha
sentito che il cazzo 6 min già aiutò
dove mi nascondo esco alla finestra ma
si può uscire che gioco di merda e vabbè
è scoperto sei bello a riparte subito
chi l'aveva miglia sei un idiota zio
cosa ci fosse messo dietro quella porta
spiega poi non c'era prima quando sono
entrato dalla porta soliti nomi di
questo politico
quanta ansia mette adesso sto gioco
rispetto a prima era in altra roba rega
mite incredibile quanto sono state come
la merda ma è andato e non ti sei bevuto
stavolta quel casa mia questa far fuori
da diventare veramente è casa mia questa
di riuscire
e vabbè sacco latte in mano attenzione
potrei cagarmi addosso
e vabbè allora sei meglio te che poi mi
ha buttato fuori ma io ero esattamente
lì quando mi hai preso quindi cosa mi
hai buttato fuori a fare se entrare dal
retro addirittura non lo so ragazzi
provo c'è una scala che non posso però
raggiungere perché chiuso porca eva
lercia mi serve un cacciavite prese vita
sta roba porca eva dove un caccia vita
temi vicini datevi un cacciavite cosa
cazzo è cosa aperto alla stufa no cos'è
non ho capito ma poi aperto tra l'altro
posso entrare fantastico non voglio
aprire la porta perché mi cavo in mano
ragazzi con quei ragazzi questa è la tv
di leone il cane fifone e non vorrei
dire la torcia piano o magari prima che
entri qualcuno piatti
piano zio
veramente sta dormendo quindi quel
deficiente può anche dormire che ne
sapevo io cos'è sta roba
vabbè dobbiamo trovare porca [ __ ]
veloce veloce no vabbè dai mica siamo
non può essere così veloce dai no vabbè
rega ma [ __ ]
allora quando ci dovrebbe essere nessuno
perché l'ho visto andare dall'altra
parte quindi perfetto a una chiave
inglese nel fei ma è giusto ma la nave
dubbi ma sono un [ __ ] io però è sì
ma dai ma la sinistra marco aveva
lanciato have a [ __ ]
c'è invece fanno vara un avevo dubbi
come con quale fisica si vabbè lasciamo
perdere
ragazzi non ancora capito a cosa serve
sull evacuo tirato prima ma continua a
correre contro bravo corri nel frattempo
do un'occhiata se non ci spiace non ci
può arrivare si è bagnato mi sa ragazzi
spero che si sia pagato prego iddio se
si è pagato posso guardare in giro un po
più tranquillamente in teoria una
sveglia per favore quello che cerca
perfetto questo potrebbe essere minuti e
veloce
una scarpa ma che cazzo ci fanno scappa
in un vero shumpert credo li avrei visto
tutto ragazzi non c'è praticamente nulla
tranne questo di mandello come che
segnava proviamo che servirà qualcosa
sta mica richeri mandello non è
possibile se no forse qua dentro ci
trovi gli attrezzi ed io disse rock a
questo gioco meraviglioso e io lo feci
bang bang ora prendiamo solo il dio che
non sia finta io adesso lo ammazzo in
teoria potrei vedere cosa c'è dietro
alla porta in teoria sicuramente la mia
immaginazione
chi morisse la famiglia vi sto facendo
ma forse muore lega non c'è dubbio
mi sto facendo sto facendo male è che ne
dici di tornare a casa tua per ho fatto
un urlo di dolore forza qualcosa serve a
[ __ ]
non posso tipo entra qua dentro ti prego
perfetto che dio ci protegga veloce ce
l'ha fatta ce l'ha fatta ce l'ha fatta
non ce la faccio sì mi sono chiuso
dentro va bene va bene la prima volta la
mia vita che sono contento di essere
chiuso dentro ci si rincontra piccolo
delinquente stronzo però stai calmo devi
stare zitto mi dà fastidio si sta roba
basta stai zitto cosa ci sta roba
salve piacere sì ma esci perfetto credo
di poter riuscire a raggiungere qualche
altra stanza di qua credo e non lo so ho
trovato una una stanza bellissima la
mappa del mondo fantastico bene allora
qua c'è una tessera con questa qua vado
nella nella stanza di sotto addirittura
fantastico ok mi butto dalla finestra
perfetto per chi è affetto e rimane un
solo problema che quello che se non le
vostra travel cook che entrò come faccio
a trovare do datemi una chiave per
aprire la maledetta porta vi prego iddio
a ecco perché se il verbo che si incassa
brutto defisce vediamone fare un
[ __ ] non ci voglio credere mai ma
veramente
non ci ho pensato proprio a frate sai
quanto quanta voglia ho di infilatelo su
per il culo questo però non posso
perfetto questa roba
la cassetta degli attrezzi qualcosa
dentro è posseduta fermi aiuto frate mi
dai una mano che la cassetta degli
attrezzi posseduta vabbè non importa
questo maledetto l'abbiamo fatta ragazzi
stiamo per entrare nella porta
misteriosà vedere che cosa nasconde il
suo decerebrato maledetto vado è zio tra
grazie gentilissima siete pronti all e
let's go
[Musica]
ragazzi cos'è stato addio una scala per
l'inferno poi c'è mi spiegate cosa
questo è quello che c'è dietro alla
porta ma che è che ma cosa fai dei riti
satanici su un pop su un pupazzo
maledetto cos'è sta roba santo di dio
che krypi nove fermi ma [ __ ] a 1 ma
lei non ci sono gli effetti sonori sui
manichini ci mancano solo quello
permesso non ci vado di vedere con c'e
dietro quella porta ok ok sto insegnando
ragazzi miei io direi che possono
chiudere qui l'episodio è stato alquanto
strano però figo ragazzi è tanto questo
gioco deve uscire all'inizio al 2017
uscirà la versione completa visto che ci
sono stati un sacco di aggiornamenti
molto più figli di quanto pensassi lo
vedete siamo 100 ragazzi consenso mio
preciso argomento è un mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook come io totale
descrizione presidiate noi ci mettiamo
il prossimo video dai ragazzi